eight fun details you missed in The Last
of Us episode 6. the monkeys we see at
the University were released by The
fireflies and in the game one of them
even bit one of the scientists
Shimmer the young horse Ellie meets is
the same one she'll ride in part two the
movie Ellie and the kids watches the
1977 film The Goodbye Girl an app title
considering Joel is about to say goodbye
to Ellie The Tipsy Bison Bar in Jackson
is the same name of the bar in the game
in the game Tommy's wife Maria is never
pregnant which could take the story in
new and unsuspecting directions Ellie's
jacket for Maria is the same one she
wears in the game in Ellie's room we can
see a poster and stuffed animal of a
giraffe or shadowing one of the game's
most memorable scenes the girl Ellie
Sees at the dining hall is most likely
Dina one of The Last of Us Part 2's
prominent characters if you want more of
these check out my channel think Story
on YouTube